das ist jetzt nicht übertrieben oder so
aber ich muss wirklich sagen das ist mit
abstand das beste produkt was ich jemals
bloßgestellt
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video jan hätte ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut er
selbst wahrscheinlich schon andere
umgebungen die alle anderen kennen die
die aber vielleicht auch nicht ich bin
gerade in meinem alten zimmer
kinderzimmer praktisch und deswegen auch
dieser wunderschöne hintergrund mit
diesen dingern die das schon seit einem
jahr oder so steht nicht fest aber nicht
ich habe überlegt irgendwie so was dran
zu sprechen aber vor dass absolut
scheiße aussieht
lass ich lieber ja genau wir haben heute
leider nicht im juli in der kamera geht
mal war juli auf dem instrument account
blende ich euch hier und mal ein und
schreibt
juli mit ihr sind die videos besser aber
das war dann freute sich oder irgendwie
sowas seid kreativ und wir machen heute
ein video das ich geplant habe auf jeden
fall ich wollte es eigentlich wirklich
sollte ein richtig geiles video werden
das haben viele von euch auf angefragt
ja mach doch mal technik gadgets von
milch ich habe die vor über einem monat
bestellt das problem ist wenn man es
zusammen fünfgeld schutz gestellt davon
sind nur drei angekommen ich hatte das
noch nie dass irgendwas nicht angekommen
ist ich war mir auch ich dachte so alex
bist du blöd hast du das irgendwie
verschlammt oder soweit ich habe mir
eigentlich sicher dass alles angekommen
ist haben diese zwei sachen allerdings
nicht mehr gefunden weswegen wir uns nur
drei games haben zum vorstellen es sind
immerhin die drei coolsten aber trotzdem
noch ein bisschen schade und ich weiß
nicht ich habe mal in meinem bestell
verlauf geschaut und da steht auch dass
die produkte noch gar nicht angekommen
sind das ist ja so und sie sind trotzdem
schon da allerdings will ich jetzt auch
nicht noch länger warten dass endlich
mal zu drehen weil das liegt schon so
lange bei mir um falls irgendwann dann
doch noch ankommen sollten wenn ihr sagt
alex auf jeden fall noch ein paar noch
einen zweiten part von technik gadgets
lasst dann nach oben da schreibt sich
die kommentare was auch immer wir
starten jetzt erst mal und zwar hier mit
das war auf jeden fall den artikel habe
ich mich richtig gefreut die noch zu
finden weil es war sehr schwer irgendwas
lustiges zu finden was man euch
vorstellen kann und was gleichzeitig
cool ist und höchstwahrscheinlich die
meisten nicht kennt und wir haben hier
ich hoffe ihr könnt es gut sehen ist
halt der nachteil wenn man mit stativ
film einen uci kat dh darüber kann man
beim joggen an
musik hören also habe ich das konzept
dahinter verstanden so sieht das produkt
auf der seite aus habe ich für acht euro
an stand gekauft sports bluetooth v3
head band running was auch immer da muss
ich mir mal ganz kurz die beschreibung
zu anschauen okay da wird jetzt auch
nicht wirklich daraus hervor was das
sein soll
vielleicht weil hier durch die durch die
bilder durch zweiten als es ist wohl
wirklich eine mütze die kann man mit
seinem handy connecten und darüber hört
man musik
ich will gar nicht wissen wie der klang
dieser musik ist sie dann daraus kommt
aber für 8 euro also das ding und ich
bin sehr sehr skeptisch sagen was man so
aber ich teste später auf jeden fall war
also das ist das erste produkt kommen
wir zur nächsten sache da freue ich mich
sehr drauf das war am teuersten ich
glaube es hat über 30 euro kostet das
natürlich trotzdem für sowas nicht viel
ist hier kann man mal sehen was dieses
paket auf dem weg hierhin wohl alles
durchgemacht hatten der leute war ich
immer ein bisschen dran gebt euch das
mal komplett demoliert ich hoffe das
funktioniert überhaupt noch und zwar ist
das ein mini beamer den man überall mit
hinnehmen kann und ich glaube auch mit
dem handy connecten kann deswegen habe
ich denn bestellt meine ich wir schauen
uns das produkt hier noch mal kurz an
also so sieht's aus 26 euro gekostet und
ja ist halt wirklich klein wie man hier
sehen kann ich schauen wir noch mal kurz
die beschreibung an es kann mit iphone
ipad oder smartphone verbunden werden
aber sie benötigen einen nhl kabel also
ich finde es schon mal gut dass das hier
auf deutsch steht kann sein dass ich das
aufgrund des kabels nicht mit meinem
handy verbinden kann aber es ist
womöglich wir probieren es gleich auf
jeden fall mal auch sonst denke ich da
einfach mal eine speicherkarte rein und
dann schauen wir mal mein eigenes video
über diesen beamer und dann kann ich
natürlich auch was die qualität sagen
weil 26 euro ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht viel für den vernünftigen diemer
ich glaube da sollte man schon so wenn
man geilen beamer haben möchte auf jeden
fall mit 800 bis 1000 euro rechnen dann
ist das auch ein gutes produkt werden
selber mal einen zu hause in köln und
dann haben wir zu guter letzt ich weiß
das ist jetzt nicht so lies hat mich
auch was ich dann genau gestellt habe
leute wir haben hier folgendes produkt
für nur zwei euro
g7 handsfree bluetooth car kit also
viele
ältere autos haben ja diesen
zigarettenanzünder oder was auch immer
ist da steckt man das ding rein kann ist
dann wohl mit seinem handy connecten und
hierüber dann telefonieren ich frag mich
nur gerade wie das dann über die
lautsprecher boxen des autos ausgegeben
werden soll also der sound wir probieren
das gleich mal meine eltern haben
nämlich ein auto das hat hat das usb ich
weiß gar nicht auf jeden fall hat es
auch so eine zigarette anzünden das
system ich glaube das hat ja auch fast
jedes auto außer mein haar doch ich habe
es auch in meinem auto also theoretisch
könnte es auch in meinem auto probieren
und dann bin ich mal gespannt ob das
ding was kann ich hatte noch so
muskelaufbau produkte bestellt die sind
leider nicht da
das tut mir sehr leid wir starten erst
mal mit dem musiker
letztlich musste kurz essen ich habe ja
schon gesagt lassen mit diesem uci kat
anfangen also hier könnt ihr nochmal
sehen so sieht das aus ich bin wirklich
mal extrem gespannt ob er funktioniert
weil an sich muss man natürlich schon
sagen so die idee dahinter finde ich gut
ich meine wenn es regnet gehen ja viele
joggen und haben dann der münze dabei
auf auch ich manchmal ja ich gehe auch
schon und dann noch darüber gute musik
zu hören
warte mal ist das überhaupt eine mütze
okay gut auf dem projekt vor das ist
auch nur ein stirnband abgebildet
irgendwie hab ich da was durcheinander
gebracht keine ahnung wieso wir dann die
mütze ist aber ich ziehe das jetzt mal
kurz um und jetzt muss ich das natürlich
irgendwie zum laufen kriegen ich weiß
nicht ob es sehen können ich habe das
jetzt gerade an gemacht hier blinkt es
jetzt leicht blau sieht man nur ganz
schwach in der kamera und ich kann das
jetzt wohl schon perez mit meinem handy
das ist immer das gute balltechnik
sachen die sind immer schon leicht
aufgeladen oder wurden halt einmal
aufgeladen und das wäre natürlich jetzt
ach guck mal ich habe schon gefunden
bitte direkt connecten wer richtig heiß
und ich bin direct connect mit leute
also extrem leicht und jetzt knalle ich
mal die musik an und ihr werdet an
meinem gesichtsausdruck direkt erkennen
ob das guter sound ist oder nicht
[Musik]
das ist jetzt nicht übertrieben oder so
aber ich muss wirklich sagen das ist mit
abstand das beste produkt was ich jemals
bloßgestellt
man muss sich das mal vorstellen erstens
diese idee und der nutzen dahinter ich
meine wir einfach ein stirnband was auch
noch die ohren stößt bei kälte ich denke
ich hoffe meister auf wasser durch
sollte es eigentlich sein und man hat
hier wirklich platz drin also wir haben
nicht so einen kleinen airport wo
möglichst viel technik in ein ganz
kleines volumen opas und die
soundqualität dann auch scheiße ist nein
wir haben viel mehr platz und hier sind
relativ große sachen drin verbaut die es
dann wohl ermöglichen für diesen
geringen preis trotzdem einen
vernünftigen sound zu erzeugen also der
sound da hier rauskommt ist jetzt nicht
das absolute sounderlebnis aber er ist
auf jeden fall vollkommen in ordnung der
basis gutes musikerlebnis und eigentlich
muss ich ihn gleich auch noch mal kurz
1000 testen muss sich jetzt punkte
vergeben 10 von 10
dann würde ich sagen machen als nächstes
mal weiter mit diesem mini projektor auf
den ich mich eigentlich am meisten
gefreut hab' da bin ich mal gespannt wie
groß das hier ist allemal das ist
wirklich sehr sehr klein
das ist das produkt vielleicht wäre
natürlich wenn er nicht mal akku braucht
na gut das kabel hier ist dabei habe ich
jetzt irgendwie zum laufen gekriegt ihr
seht das ja hier ne wahrscheinlich ganz
kurz zu erklärung ich habe meinen
macbook mit hdmi kabel hier an
angeschlossen ich habe es vor mit dem
iphone versucht das hat nicht geklappt
wir werden das aber gleich nochmal
versuchen ich habe noch eine andere idee
und dabei ist sogar auch noch eine
fernbedienung hier mit der man dem thema
steuern kann ich werde mir jetzt mal
dunkel machen mit der sony aufnehmen und
dann schauen wir uns mal das bild von
dem beamer an weil ich bin gespannt ich
sehe das schon so leicht dass ich gar
nicht mal so schlecht aus also leute ich
habe kann man hier auch die sony ist
wichtig haben alles eingestellt ihr seht
im hintergrund jetzt auch schon das bild
vom beamer und ich werde jetzt mal ein
video von mir an machen dann könnt ihr
euch vielleicht eine eigene meinung
bilden
aber meine erste meinung ist absolut
rausgeschmissenes geld ich habe noch nie
so schlechte qualität gesehen also ich
fühle mich eigentlich als könnte ich gar
nichts sehen wenn ich dieses bilder
betrachtet aber ich mache jetzt mal ein
video an und nicht klar dann versteht
ihr was ich meine
wobei man muss auch sagen das bild ist
ziemlich weit weg vielleicht liegt es
auch daran
also ich könnte jetzt noch mal versuchen
den beamer umzudrehen dann haben wir
eine kürzere distanz zur wand ihr könnt
jetzt wahrscheinlich sehen aber auch
hier muss man sagen das bild ist absolut
unscharf also wirklich man erkennt zwar
dass ich das bin aber wie das video
heißt keine chance kann man absolut
nicht lesen der sound da rauskommt ist
auch für die tonne
ich habe auch nicht mehr erwartet muss
ich sagen aber diese 26 euro kann man
dann auch einfach in die mülltonne haben
und zu guter letzt kommen wir hier zu
diesem charakter den ich ihnen jetzt mal
mit denen man dann wohl telefonieren
kann und was auch immer das werden jetzt
gleich raus finden wir sehen uns im auto
wieder
ich teste das gerät war und ich bin
gespannt ob das was kann oder halt auch
nicht so laut ich bin jetzt hier im auto
ich hoffe ihr seht mich gut und jetzt
probieren wir das ding hier mal aus bin
echt gespannt ist jetzt dieser
zigarettenanzünder und rein dass man
sich das auto noch an machen okay leute
einige zeit ist vergangen ich habe mich
ein bisschen aufgeregt weil ich es
hinbekommen habt weil das hier so schwer
ist eine frequenz manuell einzustellen
bei diesem auto ich habs jetzt
allerdings geschafft und zwar zeige ich
euch jetzt mal kurz wenn man dieses
gerät hier an macht läuft die sonne
frequenz auf und diese frequenz muss man
dann auch beim auto einstellen und dann
kann man über sein handy
[Musik]
ja also man muss sagen dieses auto hat
absolut kein bluetooth und ich kann auch
nicht irgendwie telefonieren mit
freisprechanlage wartet gibt es hier
nicht und deswegen ist so ein kleines
gadget ganz hilfreich war kompliziert
einzustellen wenn es dann erst mal
funktioniert funktioniert noch
einwandfrei deswegen auch hier für zwei
euro eigentlich ganz neue leute und
jetzt zum schluss auf jeden fall noch
kurz zu hören und zwar habe ich mir
überlegt da ich ja immer sehr sehr viele
sachen habe die ich nicht brauche und
die wahrscheinlich viele von euch
theoretisch brauchen also schließe man
ja eigentlich das produkt über stelle
ich mir auch mal und so weiter habe ich
mir gedacht du wirst einfach ab jetzt
jedes produkt weil es halt einfach
leichter ist auf dem instagram account
verlosen das heißt ich stelle euch
diesen bima dort in die story ich stelle
diese music hat dort in die story obwohl
ich dann vielleicht sogar selber
behalten und alles was in zukunft noch
verlost wird stelle ich da an die story
das einzige was sie dort machen müsst
ist keine ahnung die story zu teilen
oder halt einfach drauf reagieren oder
sonstiges steht dann alles in der story
bald deswegen zeigt auf jeden fall mein
instagram account ab alex wie wir sehen
uns morgen 19 uhr wieder da gibt's neues
video ich hoffe dieser partner
durchgefallen falls ihr noch ein paar
gold gibt noch nach oben und block
aktivieren kanal abonnieren haut rein